envie au milieu des ruines une femme
hébétée recroquevillée à côté d'une
baignoire retournée
juste au-dessous d'un bloc de béton qui
risque à tout instant de tomber
équilibre surréaliste elle est au
cinquième étage à moins d'un mètre du
vide
derrière l'image l'histoire tragique
d'Anastasia faite une Ukrainienne de 23
ans dont le monde s'est écroulé
ni pro à 130 km de la ligne de front
samedi après-midi Anastasia faite c'est
chez elle avec ses parents elle va se
reposer dans sa chambre une frappe
s'abat sur son immeuble
je venais de m'allonger dans ma chambre
et j'ai entendu un grand bruit tout
était dans la fumée dans la poussière
j'étais écrasée par la porte j'ai réussi
à me dégager j'ai compris qu'il n'y
avait plus de chambre plus rien les
appartements des voisins n'existaient
plus non plus
elle s'accroche à une guirlande de Noël
étincelle de vie et reste seul figé en
équilibre pendant plus d'une heure à cet
instant cela lui importe peu et je m'en
fichais un peu de ce qu'il se passait
pour moi je voulais juste voir mes
parents qu'on les sorte des décombres
mais ils n'ont pas survécu
à l'aide d'une grue les pompiers
réussissent finalement à la sortir des
décombres indemne elle n'a que quelques
égratignures
cet habitant de ni pro a assisté à tout
de l'explosion au sauvetage et a pris
cette photo
j'aimerais que cette photo change le
cours de la guerre peut-être que les
gens au pouvoir en Europe la verront et
comprendreont ce que la Russie fait ici
Anastasia fête sa survécu mais en
quelques mois elle a tout perdu son
compagnon soldat tué au front et ses
parents fauchés par l'explosion
l'histoire d'Anastasia mais celle de
tant d'autres ukrainiens